now a new analysis of jihadist
propaganda has revealed that Islamic
state and al-qaeda are twisting values
of Honor and solidarity to recruit
impressionable young militants there
cause the study by the Tony Blair faith
foundation examined over a hundred
online extremist videos and researchers
discovered that is and al Qaeda
propaganda promoted fundamentally
similar ideologies challenging the view
that Islamic state is more extreme while
Tony Blair's just finished delivering
that speech in New York joins me now
live Tony Blair very good to talk to you
what struck you most about this research
that their whole ideology is very much
about religion that you can't deal with
unless you deal with the religious
religious aspect of it and therefore any
strategy to defeat these people that
doesn't address the theological and
religious and scriptural basis of their
extremism isn't going to work
the second thing we found is that
unfortunately though the number of
actual violent extremists is relatively
small the number of people who share
aspects of this extremist ideology is
unfortunately quite large and some of
the clerics for example promoting this
type of ideologies you know they've got
Twitter followings running into millions
of people some of the majority
populations in some countries support
aspects of the extremism even if they
don't agree with the methods so what it
shows you I think is that if you want to
fight this as well as the security
methods and the military methods and so
on you have to deal with the ideology of
extremism why do we in the West and in
fact write the way throughout the world
that is not fundamental or extremists of
this type why do we appear to be losing
the battle of ideas and ideology
well I think we're reluctant to call it
about religion when actually it is at
least in part and fundamentally about
religion and and it's also because I
think we're you know we find it quite
hard to come to terms with the fact that
this isn't just a problem in the Middle
East it's a problem in Africa Central
Asia the Far East and it is a problem
within Islam now it's only this
extremism and the ideology is only
shared by minority people but we do have
to recognize it what it is realize that
it's possible today to have an alliance
with the majority of Muslims who
completely reject this ideology but
we've got to get organized and we've got
to to recognize that unless we deal with
this extremism that is I think deeper
and broader than we we really want to
accept then we're never going to deal
with the actual problem we have the
governments of the world who tried to
tackle it so far largely used in the
first wave bombs and missiles and guns
and not really to any great effect so
where do we go from there well I think
we have to realize this isn't gonna be
solved in a few years it's a struggle is
gonna last a generation and I think we
still haven't got down to the roots for
example particularly around the
education issue
the fact is day-in day-out millions of
young children the world over are
educated to a narrow view of religion to
a bigger the view of the world to regard
those who don't share their view of
their own religion as essentially the
enemy and one of the things that that
will be launching as a organisation the
next few months is to say that it should
be part of the global responsibility of
all countries to promote religious
tolerance root out religious prejudice
within their school systems for Murrell
informal because this stuff is this
stuff is coming up as a result of
teaching that has been spread across the
world over decades and we're now reaping
the seeds that we have sown are now
giving rise to these poisonous plants of
extremism and and hatred towards people
who are different is there more that the
the more moderate religions of the world
can do have they in some ways failed to
be at the forefront of countering this
scourge well I think there is more that
they can do and we also as I say have
real allies within Islam today
so there are clerics and scholars who
are putting forward a whole scriptural
basis for a much more modern much more
inclusive view of Islam
there are people in countries who are
who are trying to change the way that
that we tackle this extremism and root
out those that are trying to promote it
but they need us to be working in
alliance with them so you've got if
you're like if you take the Middle East
today you've got one set of issues that
are all the the military issues of
security issues they're very important
we have to deal with them but underneath
all of this if you don't deal with the
ideology and even in countries like our
own by the way if you don't deal with
this ideology you're always going to be
taking more and more security methods
sometimes military action but you're not
going to get to the heart of this and
the heart of it it is an ideology that
is poisonous and that has to be uprooted
at its source fascinating subject was
I've got you there one last thought if I
can turn to modern-day politics mr.
Corbyn has taken over as leader of the
party of which once you were the leader
and some people would see his views as
rather extreme do you welcome him
leading the Labour Party and where do
you think he's going to take it
I just thought you might ask with this
Jeremy not that I think if I'm gonna if
I'm going to talk about the Labour Party
I'll talk about it when I'm back home
not-not-not here and actually
particularly not in this museum a
memorial to 9/11 but I understand why
you have to ask me fair enough
good point thank you very much indeed
for talking about the the main point to
there the analysis carried out by your
foundation into the jihadists problem
thank you